good morning everybody it is seven
o'clock very welcome to join us on the
breakfast show this morning a train
crash in Greece that's our top story
dozens have been killed the latest on
the missing baby in Brighton live from
the scene and Sky News goes undercover
to investigate the craze of laughing gas
bought from corner shops for kicks plus
a denial from a former Health secretary
about an allegation concerning the covid
pandemic on today's show we're also
talking to the leader of the Ulster
unionist party Doug Beatty to get his
reaction to the PM's brexit deal and
we'll get Labor's View From The Shadow
Chief secretary to the treasury Pat
McFadden it's Wednesday first of March
Saint David's day
a nightmarish 10 seconds Witnesses
describe their horror as two trains
Collide in Greece killing more than 30
people
new images of runaway couple Constance
Martin and Mark Gordon moments before
their arrest as more than 200 officers
search for their two-month-old baby
the undercover Sky News investigation
into laughing gas that shows buying it
from a corner shop is as easy as getting
a loaf of bread all but one of the
stores we went into simply handed over
these canisters and even though they
didn't ask our producer any questions
they also handed over the balloons used
to inhale the gas from these
finally the ruling Party candidate
bulletinubu has won Nigeria's
presidential election but already the
opposition candidates are calling for a
re-vote we're live in Lagos
700 years of History we reveal how the
coronation chair has received a makeover
ready for the big day in May
how empty are the shells in your
Supermarket will speak to the bottom of
Iceland on the fruit and veg situation
plus we'll cook up a dish using
substitutes for what you can't get
[Music]
good morning everyone 32 people have
been killed and at least 85 injured in a
head-on train crash in Greece Emergency
Services say the passenger train was
traveling from Athens to thessalonica
when it hit a freight train the
Collision happened near the Greek
Municipality of Tempe some 235 miles
from Athens some of the casualties were
taken to hospital in the nearby city of
Larissa Siobhan Robbins hasmore
twisted and broken Carriage is derailed
these are the remains of a Greek train
after one of the deadliest crashes in
decades
it was just before midnight near the
city of Larissa when an Intercity
service collided with a freight train in
the dark passages described panic
screaming
an impact which they say felt like an
earthquake
four of the carriages came off the
tracks before several caught fire
the first sight was scary because there
were many big pieces of Steel the trains
were completely destroyed both the
passenger and freight trains the
passenger train was going about 160
kilometers per hour and there was a
clear head-on collision
people were scared very scared actually
they were looking around searching they
didn't know where they were
the passenger train had been traveling
from Athens to Thessaloniki when it
happened as Rescuers try to free the
reported 350 people on board the Army
has been called in to help
many of the injured are being treated in
Larissa with two other hospitals on high
alert
it's still too early to say what caused
this crash one of the worst in Greek
history
Siobhan the people in the first two
carriages didn't stand a chance did they
really horrific scenes coming out of
Greece this morning after this crash
just before midnight last night as I
said in the report it's believed that
the trains collided head-on and were
going at high speed when that happened
and you can see from the pictures of the
scene just how devastating that impact
was several of the carriages have
derailed one of them lying almost at a
90 degree angle to the rest of the train
and passengers on board describe
screaming a nightmarish 10 seconds they
said one man talks about having to use
his suitcase to break the window of the
train to try and get out now this crash
happened near to where another
devastating crash happened in the 1970s
and some people are saying this is more
evidence that Greeks need to update
their train system
okay for now thank you
search continuing in Brighton for that
missing baby of the Aristocrat Constance
Martin and Mark Gordon a couple have
been arrested on suspicion of gross
negligence manslaughter and are being
held by police in Sussex Aisha standing
by for us this morning Aisha
um the police think this baby's still
alive
will the search operation continues
police yesterday said that they given
the risk of the situation they must
consider the possibility the baby May
well have come to harm but they say they
are still hopeful but of course
overnight we've had more freezing
temperatures here Sub-Zero temperatures
the concern continues to grow over the
well-being of the two-month-old baby
because it's important to remember first
of all it's never received any medical
attention but on top of that as well the
last two months it's been the police
believe that Constance Martin Mark
Gordon and the baby had been camping in
open land in all sorts of temperatures
so there is the possibility that the
baby May well have been exposed to the
elements so they're going to be pushing
on with the search today they have
thrown lots and lots of resources at the
search over 200 police officers are
involved in that across the Metropolitan
Police and Sussex police they've got
various additional resources including
the use of drones police health
helicopter sniffer dogs and thermal
imaging cameras and they're really going
to be focusing on the open land they
spent a vast amount of time yesterday
searching the area here these allotments
behind us and also the wooded area
because this is nearby to where the
couple were arrested on Monday night of
course they were first arrested on
suspicion of child neglect yesterday
police said they've been further
arrested on suspicion of gross
negligence manslaughter but still in
their search their extensive search
still no sign of the baby so the search
will continue today
thank you thanks very much the former
Health secretary Matt Hancock has called
an allegation he rejected the chief
medical officers advice to test all
residents going into English care homes
for covid a distorted account of the
pandemic let's find out more should we
tomorrow's standing by for us so in what
way was it distorted morning K well Matt
Hancock the former Health secretary is
facing claims that he rejected medical
advice that all care home residents
should be tested for covid-19
sent to and from that hand
says virus spokesman that the story is
incorrect and says he was selectively
quoted I think we've got a problem with
your mic there actually tomorrow so
we're just going to
I I hope we can hear you a little better
now those messages were obtained by the
journalist Isabel oakshot who
co-authored Mr Hancock's book about the
pandemic that came out last year so she
had all those messages now in one of
them Chris Whitty the chief medical
officer tells Mr Hancock in April 2020
so about a month into the pandemic there
should be testing for everyone going
into Care Homes later in the day there's
an exchange between Matt Hancock and a
civil servant suggesting that advice was
not followed for people who were coming
into care homes from the community only
for those coming in from hospitals with
Mr Hancock saying we'd muddy the waters
to do it for everybody now of course
deaths in Care Homes have been discussed
a lot there regard as one of the big
scandals of the pandemic response now a
spokesperson for Mr Hancock told us this
says it's outrageous this distorted
account of the pandemic is being pushed
with he says partial leads spun to fit
in anti-lock-down agenda which would
have cost hundreds of thousands of lives
if followed what the messages do show is
a lot of people working hard to save
lives he goes on the full documents have
all been made available to the covid
inquiry which is the proper place for an
objective assessment so true lessons can
be learned those who argue there
shouldn't have been a lockdown ignore
the fact that half a million people
would have died had we not looked down
and for those saying we should never
look down again imagine if a disease
killed half those infected and half the
population were going to get infected
as is happening right now with avian flu
he says the story spun on Care Homes is
completely wrong what the messages show
is that Mr Hancock pushed for testing of
those going into Care Homes when that
testing was available instead of
spinning and leaks we need the full
comprehensive inquiry to ensure we are
as well prepared as we can be for the
next pandemic whenever it comes
the spokesman said that he was advised
it wasn't deliverable to test everybody
at that stage and so he is denying that
story the telegraph say that they reveal
these messages because it may be years
before they see the light of day because
the covert inquiry has not started its
hearings yet okay tomorrow for now thank
you
and a reminder that prime minister's
questions is taking place today you can
watch that live here on Sky News from
midday still to come on the program for
you this morning we'll look ahead to the
coronation with royal historian Dr Tessa
Dunlop and chief Royal correspondent
Jack Royston
we'll be speaking to PR expert Mark
Bakowski about Elon Musk the disrupter
is just sacked another 200 people at
Twitter is he brilliant or barmy or both
at 9 45 we'll be speaking to Dr David
nabaro on covid-19 and
but I think it's soon to be sir David
Navarro
now laughing gas or nitrous oxide to
give it its proper name is the latest
craze offering young people the chance
to get high it's illegal to sell it for
inhalation because it's harmful and can
devastate young lives but as guy news
investigation shows that the law is
being openly floated so let's get more
on that should we it was an
investigation by Sadia I often see these
little canisters on the floor when I
take the dogs for a walk in the park
yeah and you might be used to seeing
these little canisters but actually
young people these days are more and
more taking the larger size and we know
that the more you take of this the more
dangerous it is and that's really what's
become more common now and the London
Ambulance Service have told us that
they're taking in almost three times as
many calls and incidents related to
nitrous oxide in 2022 than they did in
2021 and we started investigating this
about two months ago when a doctor told
us that nitrous oxide is the single
biggest cause for admissions to his
Hospital Ward let's have a look at this
investigation we did
bad choices stare back at Musa every day
a nitrous oxide habit has left him
unable to walk
oh it's stupid
if you want to disable yourself carry on
even 12 year olds are misusing this drug
which is meant for pain relief in
hospitals abusing it over time can lead
to life-changing injuries
I started taking them daily because of
stress
which was obviously the dumbest thing I
could do
I would have taken them and then in the
middle of the night I go to the toilet I
got up and just fell on my face
I couldn't get up
you got it
Musa spends most of his day in bed his
body shakes his vision is blurred that
better and he's lost feeling in his
fingers and toes
you won't know until it's too late it
makes you a crackhead make sure a bit of
a junker
I didn't pitch me being like this at 20
years old definitely not don't know how
I'd live if the outcome is I can't walk
again properly I don't know how I'd
react to that swear to God
and this was moosa's stomping
luminous and
Place one one think to find nitrous
oxide we're in Birmingham to see for
ourselves how easy it is to get hold of
nitrous oxide we've been given a list of
names of shops where we're told you can
get the canisters no questions asked
let's see
it's not illegal to sell nitrous oxide
to anyone over 18 but it is to supply it
for recreational use
our producer is wearing a hidden camera
how much
30 yes okay none of the shops check his
age nor do they ask what it's for
sorry
here he's taken to a room at the back
is it in the back
watch how the canister is bagged up for
him
yeah that's fine
and look at what the shopkeeper does
next
he gives us balloons
climate change
and in another shop
like getting Cutlery with a takeaway
all but one of the stores we went into
simply handed over these canisters and
even though they didn't ask our producer
any questions they also handed over the
balloons used to inhale the gas from
these
[Music]
it's not illegal to inhale but ministers
are calling for tighter controls that
could see more prosecutions more fines
and tougher prison sentences what we
don't want to be doing is criminalizing
users I don't see how that helps the
problem that's going to drive it
underground
I think much tighter action needs to be
on the supply chain this stuff should be
sold business to business it shouldn't
be sold in corner shops push up against
my hand Dr Nichols says he's seeing more
and more patients like Musa he calls it
a bigger problem than cocaine seeing
young people with completely avoidable
preventable neurological disability is
far from a joke it's really upsetting
just pop their arms up like that for us
spread your fingers this month the
government is set to start consultation
on the sale and use of nitrous oxide
even by the time they do musa's doctors
say it's unlikely he'll be walking again
sarya choudhary Sky News
fascinating stuff so anyway where can we
learn more about this so we have a piece
online as well so you can go on online
and read that and just to let you our
viewers know Musa is out of hospital now
but he is still uh having to use
crutches to walk but he's very happy to
know that lots of campaigners are trying
to do something about this and there are
calls for things like a band perhaps on
sale and possession a sort of like the
type that they have in the Netherlands
but that's all being discussed the
advisory Council on the misuse of drugs
is currently taking in evidence to try
and use some of that feedback to
formulate an answer for the government
okay fascinating thanks very much indeed
thanks a lot
in other news MPS a warning that NHS
England will not meet its first cancer
recovery targets a report from the
Public Accounts committee says the NHS
is over optimistic about what it hopes
to achieve and is already falling short
over 7 million people are record high
are on waiting lists for elective
procedures and Cancer Care in England
for Cancer Care waiting times are worse
than ever just 62 percent of urgent GP
referrals started treatment within the
target period of 62 days well below NHS
England's Target of 85 percent last
August 2 600 patients had been
waiting more than two years to start
cancer treatment the committee's chair
Dave Meg Hillier says figures are the
tip of the iceberg
well we've seen over optimism on
delivery of this recovery plan um and
during covid there were there were plans
to ramp it up but they haven't been
delivered as they should have done and
we're now seeing one in 10 people
waiting over 104 days for basic Cancer
Treatments so you know this is just the
tip of the iceberg there are also
stretched staff
um uh you know over uh stretched
Services uh partly as a result of covid
but they predicted they would deliver
this and they're not we don't think
they're going to
on a spokesperson for the Department of
Health and Social care told us the NHS
has already made strong progress in
tackling the covid backlogs virtually
eliminating weights of over two years of
treatment we're working to reduce the
62-day cancer backlog which has fallen
nine percent since peaking in 2020 but
we know there is more to do
some of today's other headlines for you
know
Elaine Maxwell has launched an appeal
against her sex trafficking conviction
she says she was immune from prosecution
and claims her trial was tainted the 61
year old is serving a 20-year prison
term for helping Jeffrey Epstein
sexually abuse young girls
China's accused the U.S of abusing state
power by forcing federal workers to
delete Tick-Tock from government devices
over cyber security concerns Tick Tock
has long faced allegations it gives
users data to the Chinese government but
China said the U.S government was
exploiting National Security concerns to
penalize foreign companies
police have released four men who were
being questioned about the attempted
murder of detective Chief Inspector John
Caldwell in Oma last Wednesday two other
men aged 47 and 71 are still being held
for questioning Mr Caldwell remains in a
critical but stable condition in
hospital
The Culinary world is in shock because
the man known by many is the best chef
in the world has lost a Michelin star
this year's Michelin guide has
downgraded geese Savoy's restaurant
Monet De Paris from three to two stars
it was named the best restaurants in the
world by La liste for six consecutive
years
let's have a look what the papers are
saying this morning the times reporting
that Rishi sunak has appealed to Tory
MPS to back him and finally get brexit
done thought it already had been
pledging to push ahead with or without
the support of the dup we'll see about
that the guardian's front has a warning
from Parliament spending watchdog that a
14 billion pound plan to reduce NHS
backlogs caused by covid is failing to
meet targets just heard from the NHS
about that one haven't we the telegraph
has a story involving the former Health
secretary Matt Hancock and leaked text
messages his spokesperson is strongly
disputing that he ignored expert advice
during the pandemic
The Daily Mail leads with police fears
that the baby of constance Martin and
Mark Gordon has come to harm after the
pair were arrested on Monday night
and the Ft leads with the report that
Jaguar Land Rover owner Tata Motors is
demanding more than 500 million pounds
of government Aid to build a new battery
Factory in Britain
more sightings of the Northern Lights
have been captured but not from the
usual viewpoints here we go EasyJet
passengers on a flight from Iceland to
the UK had a great view of the northern
lights after a pilot made of 360 turn
over the North Sea the maneuver allowed
passengers on both sides of the aircraft
to see the sparkling display in the
night sky
uh later we'll speak to Dr Francisco
Diego from the Department of physics and
astronomy at University College London
to tell us all about the Northern Lights
I should say if you've taken any
pictures of the northern lights over the
last couple of days being able to see
them really well haven't we in the UK do
you send them to us and we will share
them with the world throughout the
course of the program you can tweet us
directly at K Burley or you can use a
hashtag cable and we'll be able to find
it from there a quick look at the
weather
uh conditions remain quiet until the
weekend when we start to see some cold
air in the North
it's that time of the morning here's our
climate dashboard coming up right now
there you go uh looking at Cole no coal
at all today a lot of gas though almost
two-thirds of our power mix is gas today
only 17
Renewables and I thought it was windy
over the last couple of days but there
you go this is what we're at at now 1.26
degrees higher than in 1880 and as far
as CO2 emissions are concerned in
millions of tons this huge number here
in real time according to the University
of Oxford looking at other news for you
and here we go there you go you
recognize them what were they doing they
were just spinning class uh yesterday
the prince and princess took part in a
timed distance spin during a visit to
aberraven Leisure and fitness center in
Port Talbot they were there to meet at
local communities and hear about how
Sport and exercise can support mental
health and well-being
can you guess who won of course you can
it was Kate and here she is taking pride
in her winners trophy
no Wishy sunak is working hard to sell
his Windsor framework last night talking
to Tory back benches in the Commons
joining us now is Richard Graham a
member of the 1922 committee which is
basically shop steward bench committee I
suppose for those MPS who wouldn't have
a voice otherwise and it sounds as
though you're all quite happy with this
new deal
uh well I can't speak for absolutely
everybody okay but I think I can happily
share with you that you know my own
feelings are very powerfully about what
a great deal this is and I think that's
the Instinct of pretty well colleagues
as well
um you're supportive of the Prime
Minister as you're saying there but
you're aware that um not all that not
all Northern Ireland unionists are it's
still
um a battle that he might have to fight
it's not a done deal in other words
well I think he understood the the key
uh Way Forward was to try and find
practical solutions to the Practical
problems for the people of Northern
Ireland and then try and bring in if you
like all the political parties to
support this so that we get back to the
power sharing former government in
Northern Ireland that so badly needed
and that means giving those political
parties a bit of time to look at the
detail of the deal and obviously the dup
are critical to this
um but I think you know there is a
strong feeling that this does make a
difference for so many people in
Northern Ireland and I think it's going
to be difficult for the dup to strongly
object to this they they will probably
say that it's not perfect
they want two weeks to look at the deal
is that reasonable to ask for
I think so and the timing of this is is
quite good in the run-up to the 25th
anniversary of the Belfast Good Friday
agreement isn't it
why is it reasonable
um to ask for two weeks and yet others
have looked through the detail I'm sure
they've got lawyers everywhere looking
at it and I'm sure they can do it
quicker than that can't they
well look I think it's for them to
decide and I think the prime minister is
very much of the view that if it takes a
few days longer for some parties to look
at it and decide their view in the
bigger scheme of things that's a small
price to pay for what will be a historic
achievement in resolving the issues left
over from the Northern Ireland protocol
what if they decide they don't like it
well that that would be very sad but we
can't sort of deal with the the
hypothetical issues and they're very
conscious as I think we all are that we
have to have the quality of Public
Services delivered in Northern Ireland
that the people from Northern Ireland
you know deserve and that means having a
sitting government in place making
decisions and
and overseeing all the public services
and and without that it's very difficult
I think for Northern Ireland to move
forward so their objections were all
about the Northern Ireland protocol and
the fact that in practice this did mean
that Goods moving from Great Britain to
Northern Ireland were being treated as
if they were crossing an international
border and that was obviously wrong and
those are the issues that the Prime
Minister I think is brilliantly resolved
not least through creating the Green
Lane for goods coming from from GB to ni
but stuff going through the Green Lane
can still be randomly stopped can't it
well it it the only checks left will be
those to to stop Smugglers and criminals
so it'll be intelligence-led
yeah but it's still a border if they can
do random checks and random stops and I
think you still also have to provide
certain amounts of paperwork
you can do random checks anywhere in in
the UK if the police believe the delore
is carrying something which is you know
going somewhere for which it isn't
documented and shouldn't be going so I I
don't see that as a huge problem but you
you may well be right in saying that the
dup May point to that as as one of their
residual issues but the key thing is is
whether there's enough in it for them to
to realize that this actually is hugely
helpful for their voters and therefore
something ultimately to support no but
that you still need to provide instead
of 80 pieces of information being needed
at Customs you'll need to provide 21
pieces so there is still a border
within the Green Lane burdensome Customs
New York City and I'm quoting directly
will be scrapped and replaced with data
sharing of ordinary existing commercial
information so the data sharing is the
is the key to it funnily enough on the
brexit select committee uh after the
election in 2017 we looked at all these
things in huge detail and I remember
vividly I think it was John Thompson of
hmrc saying that it would be possible to
have a red and green Lane with data
sharing to get around some of these
issues but the systems weren't in place
they wouldn't be ready for some years to
come so in one sense time has proved
helpful and the evolution of the
technology needed and to be able to show
the EU that the data sharing would work
and all the rest of it so very practical
way for you I'm not sure if you've had
chance to read your Daily Telegraph yet
this morning what's going on with Matt
Hancock
um Chris which apparently he rejected
Chris what is advised to test all
residents going to English care homes
from covert
um well no hey I I certainly haven't
looked to the Daily Telegraph and B this
is presumably something going back some
years into the pandemic is it
uh yeah I it's um text messages WhatsApp
messages
um that have been handed over to a third
party they have been trawled through and
now the allegation is which he rejects
um that uh Chris he rejected Chris
Whitley's advice to test all residents
going into English care homes for coven
calling it a distorted account of the
pandemic
um he's rejecting it as I said but
if he did do that which he rejects he
will keep throwing that in so the
lawyers are happy
um what does that leave us when the
health secretary was not testing
everybody that went into Care Homes
um look there are a whole series of of
questions uh to do with the pandemic
which you know will be resolved by an
investigation and and Matt Hancock will
will have to No Doubt answer any of
those specific allegations from Chris
Wishy
um and we'll hear you know both sides of
of of that of that of that view I mean
I'm much more focused on what's
happening today and moving forward and I
think the strength of the Union in the
United Kingdom
we've done quite a lot on the union
let's go back to Matt Hancock are you
not at all concerned and want to know
more about that
but yes and I'm sure we will
thanks for joining us on the program
hello again everybody now you've seen it
in slapstick movies now in Mafia bosses
Broken Heart of a Sardinian prison using
an old-fashioned method of Escape
Marco radiano known as polony don't know
why it's quite it's interesting though
isn't it scramble to the top of the wall
knotted together some bed sheets and
used them to drop to Freedom 39 year old
member of the Gargano Mafia was serving
19 years for Mafia crimes the prison
said it was a very well prepared Escape
he knotted some blankets together 32
people have been killed and at least 86
injured in a head-on train crash in
Greece Emergency Services say a
passenger train was traveling from
Athens to thessalonica when it hits a
freighter train
meantime search is continuing in
Brighton for the missing baby of the
Aristocrat Constance Martin and Mark
Gordon the couple have been arrested on
suspicion of gross negligence
manslaughter and are being held by
police in Sussex
where is the baby that's the question
everybody wants the answer to this
morning now in May the king will take
his seat at the coronation but first
it's getting a little bit of TLC over
time the chair has survived vandalism by
schoolboys and attacked by suffragettes
and it's in much need of Renovations let
me just grab my notes and I'm going to
take you over to have a longer chat
about this of the royal historian Dr
Tessa Dunlop and chief Royal
correspondent at Newsweek Jack Royston
hi both good to see you thanks very much
indeed tell me about this chair
quite a history of course it was
originally built around 1300 for this
stolen Stone of schoon Edward the first
Hammer of the Scots comes down
controversially brings it from Scotland
and it's built this wonderful sort of
Oak two meter high edifice to encase the
stone now when it was used as a first
coronating not how to use that actually
it's very American as a chair to Crown a
king or queen in that again is
controversial we know for certain in
1399 it was used for Henry IV but
there's thoughts that it was certainly
used in the coronation in some way from
earlier in the 14th century
yeah so some people are accustomed to
you know glittering gold Thrones maybe
it's priced and this is predominantly
made out of wood with some gold gilting
gold painting on it but
um it's what is so special about it is
it's extraordinary history it's the uh
oldest piece of furniture in Britain
that's still used for its original
function and like you said it's just
survived all these you know vandalized
by schoolboys in the 18th and 19th
century I I didn't imagine that school
boys did that kind of thing back then
but yeah we've always done that
Scorpio's always done that and it's the
same thing it was just people you know
carving ineffectively I was here and you
know this in such a 1800
um and it just I can't help thinking
that one day and sometime in the future
there's going to be a future series of
the crown that uses this as a kind of
metaphor for Charles because you know
here he is he's survived his scandals in
the past as well just that the chair has
survived all these uh vandalism by the
younger generation and yet it still has
this extraordinary role to play in
British life does the Queen have one as
well well this is this is the thing so
there's only been one joint coronation I
when a king and queen of equal standing
both reigning
um were coronated together and that was
Mary and William of course touch William
comes in and what offends me is that
Mary had the greater right to the throne
and yet William sits on the big chair
um so there will be another chair
obviously for the queen consort this has
become
sequence or is she the queen well
they're all Queen consorts because they
don't reign in their own right they're
only uh sitting on the throne alongside
their husband when Charles ceases to be
king then Camilla is is no longer as it
were part of of the Monarch in that way
but but can I pick you up on that so
when it was Queen Elizabeth the queen
mother she was still called Queen
Elizabeth even though she was no longer
Queen yeah she retained the title Queen
but she was no longer part of you know
attached to the king the reigning King
so she leaves Buckingham Palace Etc
um therefore the consult point is
significant but if you're Queen regnant
like Queen Elizabeth II was it doesn't
matter what happens to your husband he's
your accessory as poor old Philip was
for so many years
um but if you are their Queen because
your husband's King you are only in that
position as long as he is reigning and
that's where the consort part is
significant but of course it just
becomes shortened to Queen and you
become Queen Mary Queen Elizabeth
Etc Queen Camilla I've got to say I'm my
big distinction was between princess
concert versus queen console by the time
your Queen's not consult your queen
Camilla in my in my view and I think the
public will go there I think there is
perhaps a little bit of a transition
period where people are getting their
heads around it because even just now
when you said the queen I kind of
initially thought you meant Queen
Elizabeth II and people will feel that
way for a long time but she is Queen
Camilla once so for instance if Camilla
outlived King Charles we would no longer
refer to her as the queen I bet we would
do you think so I know because we'd have
another queen which have Queen Kate yeah
so it would be Queen Camilla so like
Queen Elizabeth the queen mother and she
took a while by the way she was quite an
ego the Queen Mother people always
thought she thought she actually
wouldn't be rather like being uh married
to the king even though she protested at
the beginning
um and she took a while you know she
wore those soft hats and restyled
herself Queen Elizabeth the Queen Mother
quite a lot that sort of sopped her ego
some of that yeah um apparently uh the
grandchildren are going to have a role
in the coronation I'm reading yeah
that's what we're hearing and I know
Tessa has some strong perspectives of
this so I'll let her take over in just a
second but yeah no I think I think they
were always going to be there and they
were always going to be present I think
it's quite interesting that we're
hearing that they're going to play a
more formal role and you know yeah it
could bring a slight degree of
controversy into it dare I say it
so cute
poking the old eye isn't it fairy he is
the son of the king and suddenly these
sort of second-hand grandchildren are
coming along it's a sort of Pippa
second-hand grandchildren well she
watches at the palace you know she's the
she's the queen console and these are
her grandchildren and I understand they
they want to be part of the ceremony and
that's right and proper and given a
place on a Pew but I'm not sure about
being part of the official ceremony a
lot of people have said oh this is
blended family this is modern monarchy
and I hear that it's not diverse
monarchy a bit like Camilla's companions
aren't hugely diverse I wonder who this
is speaking to it feels really quite
home counties I was in stently um at
University at the same time as as Tom
and he and he went through it you know
it wasn't it wasn't a great people yeah
it wasn't a great time in the early 90s
to be the Sonic Miller I you know
they've stood by their mother and their
grandmother and they're rightly proud of
the journey she's been on and the
rehabilitation she's experienced but I'm
not sure that this if we're trying to
slim down monarchy this is really
serving to that purpose and I speak
totally from a personal point of view
when I heard it it was being sold very
much in some of the Tableau presses this
great kind of modern blended family and
I thought look quite narrow and a bit
slowly Pony to me some of the narrative
and I think how what about including
some of the Commonwealth or in the
official ceremony some some fresh faces
something that kicks it along a bit you
brush up um the chap who has written a
book about being the spare uh Harry of
course yeah
um there he is behind me
um apparently they have been evicted
from their home and
um Andrew will get their new home or
count it as his new home because they've
been evicted this is obviously a big
moment and assuming that it is in fact
correct
um Harry and Megan I think we all see a
lot less of them in Britain I think it's
really important to remember that
there's much more to this than simply a
place to lay your hats because in
Frogmore they had the protection of the
police who guard the private estate
there and there was actually at the time
of the Jubilee they came to Britain and
barely left Frogmore because they didn't
have police protection to take them from
here and there which is why we only saw
them at the official events they were
invited to they had police protection
for that and then they had police
protection at Frogmore and they did
nothing else for that reason so the fact
they're losing Frogmore means they may
not even feel safe stepping in Britain
at all
um so if this is correct then it has
Mega ramifications for their
relationship with the country
strange Optics though doesn't it Jack
because the narrative at least in the
sun this morning is roxit means that
they're relinquishing Frogmore I wonder
if they're going to be paid back or in
some way recoup the renovations the
millions of pounds of Renovations that
they then paid you'll remember
initiative
um and that Andrew is going to replace
them in this small cottage I mean he
doesn't want to but he doesn't want to
five bedrooms five in comparison I think
it's about 30 in the Royal Lodge I don't
know I haven't counted the role but the
bedrooms and the Royal Lodge recently
but it's much bigger it's a sort of
wedding cake of a place but nonetheless
the Optics aren't great are they Andrew
getting Harry's Gaff I I know that
they've had terrible polling I know
they've been in discrete I
he's a man in pain he's angry and I just
think our monarchy is I'm I'm a
monarchist it needs to be a broad
shouldered institution and if we're
including uh Camilla's grandchildren I I
want to include them it's about
forgiveness Redemption it's about
finding a way forward and I don't want
to see them both in the Abbey I want to
see them in the Abbey and I don't really
want them I would like them both there
with their children if Camilla's
grandchildren are going to be there if
they're not too little to endure I think
it's going to be two hours surely a
little part of them they can be slotted
in and slotted out so we have a crash in
the abuse yeah maybe why not we're
building all sorts
but I also think Frogmore needs to I'm
hoping that this that this will be just
rumor and gossip but I it may well be
the case and I and it may be instigated
by the house of Montecito that they want
to park all their their guns as it were
on their American lawn and they don't
want to see her meaning Harry and Megan
that's the name of where they are in in
California do you want to see them at
the coronation I I think it would be
interesting to see them at the
coronation I mean you know this might
not be the kind of thing to say but it
would be really interesting to see the
Dynamics between them and other members
of the royal family like they'd say they
get they'd say they wind up face to face
with William and Kate efforts might be
made to sit them separately but let's
say they do I mean it would be really
interesting to kind of try to get a
litmus test on how these two couples get
along after everything but that's just I
feel that's a little bit so popular I
just want them there to make sure that
our monarchy represents something more
than sort of Southeast England which is
what what it feels like a little bit if
you've got I think they're called lowie
and Eliza and I'm sure they're really
lovely girls I've not got no doubt and
Charles by the way apparently very close
to his step-grandchildren but there is
something about Harry and Megan that
speaks more internationally yes flawed
yes and pain but makes our monarchy
resonate in a broader more Global way
that he is head of the Commonwealth
chance he does have 14 other Realms I'm
really wondering how the coronation is
going to speak to people and and places
outside of Britain well he's got a three
book deal I think um uh Harry so he'll
need some stuff for the other two
perhaps behind the scenes at the
coronation with the crash with the crash
thanks very much for coming I really
enjoyed that thank you
now after days of counting Nigeria's
ruling Party candidate Bola tinubu has
been declared the winner of the most
competitive presidential election since
the country became a democracy in 1990
the two opposition candidates have
demanded a rerun of the vote due to
delays that they say could have caused
irregularities
I'm going to be talking more about that
very shortly indeed our correspondent at
the same meantime seven several thousand
miles from home but you wouldn't know it
check this out this walrus has been
spotted by a fisherman sunbathing on
Scotland's West Coast well away from its
traditional Arctic habitat it's the
first time a walrus has been seen in the
in the Hebrides is this the same walrus
that keeps getting on boats and sinking
it in in the Dublin Bay it may be him
I'm not sure his nickname Thor anyway
um he was spotted in Scarborough earlier
this year I wonder if he's the same one
very similar though the one walrus how
can you tell it from another I don't
know there you go Elon Musk sacked more
Twitter staff this weekend including
some of his most senior people he did it
by uh locking workers out of systems or
firing them by email ask cars repeatedly
come under scrutiny over the way he
manages his Workforce joining me now is
PR and branding expert Mark murkowski hi
it's good to see you thanks for joining
us on the program what's he up to well
he's obviously a very disruptive figure
I mean he's uh he's he's taken a massive
risk with this he sees this as a a
powerful platform for him
um if we look back at what he's achieved
it's been phenomenal
um in terms of the Tesla he's a
controversial figure
but let's face it you know Twitter is a
very powerful medium
um numbers are dropping but they're
still minuscule but it's losing a hell
of a lot of money and if he's got Grand
plans for this and that's probably in
his head then somehow he's got a stem
the sort of uh you know the loss of
blood the loss of money that it's going
through at the moment Twitter grew very
very quickly if we think about it but of
course now with Tick Tock Instagram
Facebook still has more engagement than
Twitter you know he's got to do
something with it but you can never
quite understand what musk is thinking
in his head but his achievements as a
direct as a disruptive and builder of
phenomenal um you know game-changing
Industries in this time he's a master so
you think he will take Twitter on to
bigger and better things
well he has to or is going to be one of
the most phenomenal flops we've seen in
modern you know sort of Tech History I
guess
um he is he's he's determined but the
way that he's treating staff the way
controversially is bringing some of
those deceptive figures like Trump and
like Andrew take back online giving them
he's you know he obviously is a great
believer in free speech
um but it's been controversial and it's
making news and he's not frightened of
actually being at the center of that
tension he's no fashion showman in many
ways yeah free speech or free publicity
both isn't it I mean if you're going to
re-engage with people you can get those
numbers I mean Twitter's Revenue comes
from advertising
um predominantly now getting so many
adverts on my Twitter feed now that I
didn't get before well you do I mean it
is changing and the same with Instagram
You could argue that you know Instagram
is not as pure as it used to be
um all these all these
um all these apps and whatever you know
I have to you know are free to us
they're going to make money well you
know I have a very disruptive effect in
my opinion in terms of democracy and the
change that's been brought on I mean
it's erode in analog media to such in
such a way we're seeing the the effect
it has on younger people we're seeing
Twitter with someone argue is a pretty
profoundly negative influence but people
still use it people are still connected
to it and that's the interesting thing
as much as we moan and we feel troubled
by this we still engage with it sucking
people by email locking them out of the
office it means that he won't
necessarily be able to attract decent
people to do the job going forward
um could he is it possible that Elon
Musk could be canceled
could he also speak again let's think of
all the stuff Elon Musk has done in the
past I mean even with here when the the
you know the the famous sort of cave
rescue the unfortunate term he used on
on that that man who went to rescue
called him you know pedo guy
um and somehow he seemed to sort of get
above that you know he's he's played
with shares he's you know promoted
crypto
um smoked a joint lie bugged up things
he's got an incredible sort of Survivor
complex around it and you know he is a
very very wealthy man
um and he's persuaded that this stock to
be bought by some influential people
around him
um you know you can't write this guy off
or whatever goes forward then you know
negative or positive he's the story
we're talking about him now okay it's
good to talk to you thanks for coming in
to see us we really appreciate it thank
you